die zahl der korona infektionen steigt
auch heute weiter gleichzeitig beginnt
morgen an vielen schulen wieder der
unterricht
dieses dokument öffnet türen geimpfte
sollen damit den israel wieder ins
theater können oder ins fitnessstudio
und der könig von melbourne novak
djokovic gewinnt zum neunten mal die
australian open
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers ich begrüße sie ganz
herzlich guten daten die in allen
norbert könig ist hier nachher für den
sport guten abend hallo
es könnte so schön sein ein land taut
auf das erste frühlingswochenende nach
frost eis und schnee kein wunder dass
viele einfach nur raus wollten in die
sonne
es waren sehr viele wie hier am dümmer
see in niedersachsen
die behörden in travemünde haben ein
sogenanntes betretungsverbot verhängt
ihnen wurden strand spielplatz und
promenade zu voll
denn es gibt nach wie vor auch grund zur
sorge wegen dieser zahlen
das robert koch institut meldet 7676
neuinfektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 1562 mehr als vergangenen sonntag
145 menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
virus gestorben
auch die sieben tage incidents steigt
den bisherigen höchststand gab es kurz
vor weihnachten mit 197,6 aktuell liegt
die inzidenz bei 60,2 und ist damit den
zweiten tag in folge gestiegen
zehn bundesländer öffnen allerdings
morgen wieder schrittweise schulen und
kitas volker check homeschooling ag die
meisten die an diesem wochenende ins
würzburger testzentrum kommen wollen
eine bescheinigung dass sie das virus
nicht haben denn ab morgen geht es
wieder in die schule den ersten corona
test ihres lebens haben viele kinder gut
überstanden
auch schön beizubringen dass es wirklich
nicht schlimm ist dass es nicht wehtut
dass es auch ganz ganz schnell geht und
das ist einfach wichtig ist dass zu
machen
in sachsen und niedersachsen sind die
grundschüler bereits zurückgekehrt zehn
weitere bundesländer kombiniert dazu
schülervertreter glauben dass bei den
älteren jahrgangsstufen alltags masken
nicht ausreichend wir gehen wir sind im
öffentlichen nahverkehr überall braucht
die medizinischen masken weil einfach
ganz klar ist die schützen einfach
besser teilweise ffb zwei masken einem
sogar besser noch selber und deshalb die
frage warum nicht in den schulen mehr
schutz für lehrerinnen und kita erzieher
man die gewerkschaften an viele stört
dass diese berufsgruppen nicht bevorzugt
geimpft werden konkrete forderung diese
beschäftigten sollen in die gleiche impf
gruppe wie ärzte nach
gesundheitsminister sparen befürwortet
das jetzt auch bundesbildungsministerin
carlitscheck beide berufsgruppen nehmen
aufgaben wahr die für unsere ganze
gesellschaft von ganz großer bedeutung
sind was sich auch in der imk
priorisierung zeigen sollte bereits
morgen könnte eine entsprechende
grundsatzentscheidung der
landesgesundheitsminister fallen wenn
dann noch die korona verordnung geändert
wird könnte das impfen
bald beginnen weltweit ganz vorne bei
den impfungen gegen korona liegt israel
fast die hälfte der einwohner bekannt
schon mindestens eine dosis knapp ein
drittel auch schon die zweite die daten
aus israel zeigen dass der wirkstoff von
biotech pfizer sehr erfolgreich
erkrankungen verhindert und vielleicht
auch die übertragung des virus
wer geimpft ist darf seit heute in
israel wieder mehr als andere details
aus tel aviv von michael warum fast ein
halbes jahr haben sie im dauer lockdown
auf diesen moment gewartet die
sportstudios machen wieder auf
allerdings nur für die mit grünem pass
also zweifach kämpfte oder cupid 19
genießen die freude dass endlich
bewegung in den kampf gegen das virus
kommt ist groß endlich das gefühl von
freiheit und sicherheit wir kehren zur
arbeit und zum training zurück
hoffentlich auch zum alltag und das
firma danach sieht es fast schon wieder
aus den israel hebt seinen lockdown
weitgehend auf herrlich fünf monate sind
eine lange zeit früher kamen wir täglich
ein gefühl wie nachhausekommen doch
während geschäfte und museen für alle
öffnen sind puls theater und hotels nur
mit grünen passt zugänglich die vorteile
des grünen platzes sollen der wachsenden
impfmüdigkeit entgegenwirken denn was
nützen immer neue erfolgsmeldungen über
die wirksamkeit des impfstoffs wenn der
nicht genutzt wird
tatsächlich zeigen alle studien dass der
bayer wirkstoff zu 99 prozent vor
ansteckung schützt das auch die
weitergabe des virus durch bereits
geimpfte drastisch reduziert wird ist
wahrscheinlich aber laut experten noch
nicht ausreichend belegt
wir haben bisher noch keinen eindeutigen
beweis für den einfluss des impfstoffs
auf die infektiosität also die
weitergabe an andere solch ein ergebnis
könnte man nur von einer künftigen
längeren testreihe ableiten
und so tritt der modellversuch israel in
eine weitere phase mit neuen freiheiten
maske und abstandsregeln allerdings
bleiben jetzt weitere wichtige
nachrichten von diesem sonntag das
brutale vorgehen der sicherheitskräfte
in myanmar stößt international auf viel
kritik
uno und bundesregierung fordern
gleichermaßen ein ende der gewalt auch
heute gingen wieder zehntausende
menschen gegen den militärputsch auf die
straße unter großer anteilnahme wurde
eine 20-jährige studentin beigesetzt ein
polizist hatte ihr in den kopf
geschossen
insgesamt kamen bei den protesten bisher
mindestens drei menschen ums leben seit
1700 jahren gibt es jüdisches leben in
deutschland und trotzdem immer noch
vorurteile und ausgrenzung
dass aber auch die deutsch jüdische
geschichte ist thema vieler
veranstaltungen die in diesem
jubiläumsjahr stattfinden
vor 1700 jahren wurde eine kaiserliche
verordnung erlassen die die existenz
jüdischen lebens in deutschland belegt
dort ferber jetzt über damals und heute
kocer durch die krisen in der jüdischen
gemeinde düsseldorf organisieren sie in
diesen tagen ihr gemeindeleben online
sie sind hier vielstimmig und sie sind
offen
auf dem alltag ja du bist der erste jude
dich kennengelernt habe ja aber dann
muss man eben dafür sorgen dass es dass
es irgendwie begegnungen gibt mit diesem
edikt aus dem jahr 321 beginnt
nachweislich die deutsch jüdische
geschichte
1700 jahre jetzt wird in köln synagoge
das gedenkjahr feierlich eröffnet mit
dem bundespräsident als schirmherren die
bundesrepublik deutschland ist nur
vollkommen bei sich wenn juden sich hier
vollkommen zu hause fühlen das zu
gewährleisten das ist auftrag aus 1700
jahren geschichte jüdischen lebens in
deutschland nun ein festjahr mit vielen
begegnungen und jüdischer kultur online
und vielleicht real mehr wissen über das
judentum könne auch helfen
antisemitismus zu bekämpfen
wenn quer durch die gesellschaft gezeigt
wird wie vielfältig jüdisches leben ist
wenn juden nicht länger als fremd
empfunden werden dann können wir
erreichen dass manches vorurteil über
juden endlich ein für alle mal
verschwindet in düsseldorf bewacht die
polizei die synagoge auch das ist
realität in diesem fest ja dass nicht
nur ein jubeljahr ist und jetzt so ein
alptraum mit glücklichem ende in den usa
gerät ein passagierflugzeug in der luft
den brand und verliert teile eines
triebwerks den piloten gelingt die
notlandung verletzt wird offenbar
niemand die boeing 777 war kurz nach dem
start in denver in schwierigkeiten
geraten ein triebwerk brannte dessen
trümmer stürzten auf ein wohngebiet und
auf einen sportplatz trotz des
zwischenfalls kehrte die maschine mit
rund 240 menschen an bord sicher zum
flughafen zurück wunder der technik und
fliegerisches können auf jeden fall
jetzt kommt norbert unter sport ja mit
der absoluten nummer eins im
männertennis neun mal im finale und zum
neunten mal gewonnen novak djokovic ist
der herrscher des grand-slam-turniers
von melbourne heute mit einer
demonstration der stärke
gegen daniel mit werde zum unfall und
schön dieses bild geht um die welt als
novak djokovic alle last von den
schultern fällt der matchball gegen
daniel medwedew steht stellvertretend
für das gesamte spiel in dem djokovic
seinen russischen gegner spätestens nach
ende des ersten satzes schlichtweg
dominierte der serbe ist in der klaren
mehrzahl der ballwechsel der spieler mit
den besten ideen
nach noch nicht einmal zwei stunden kam
djokovic sein glück in die welt
hinausschreien für den 33 jährigen ist
es bereits der achte erfolg bei 1
grand slam turnier in der fußball
bundesliga trennten sich augsburg und
leverkusen mit 1 zu 1 rb leipzig
verkürzt den abstand auf tabellenführer
bayern münchen durch das 13 0 bei hertha
bsc auf zwei punkte
den letzten titel bei der alpinen ski wm
in cortina d'ampezzo holt sich im slalom
der norweger sebastian voß zu lübeck -
straße landet auf platz 15 bei der
biathlon-wm in pokljuka gibt es 14
medaillen für norwegen das siebte gold
der skandinavier gewinnt im massenstart
stuhler hall ehrgeiz an peiffer wird
zwölfter die beste deutsche schneidet in
ihrem rennen etwas besser ab franziska
preuß mit hohen erwartungen gestartet
gerät gleich beim ersten schießen in die
defensive fällt nach einer strafrunde
zurück auf rang 22
doch die 26 jährige kämpft sich zurück
in die top ten
beim letzten schießen fünf weiße
scheiben der wm titel geht an die
fehlerfreie österreicherin lisa theresa
hauser auf rang zwei und drei country
volt und eckhoff aus norwegen am ende
ein guter sechster platz für franziska
preuß einzelmedaille einfach mit kämpfen
wir jetzt leider mit geschafft dann wie
wir es nächstes jahr wieder
damit bleiben die deutschen frauen
erstmals seit 24 jahren ohne wm
einzelmedaille
man gibt es nicht mehr gibt sich norbert
hat doch gereicht
ein perfektes notweg in kassel nach
vielen dank der wetterbericht kann sich
sehen lassen morgen wird fast überall
sonnig bei höchsttemperaturen zwischen
10 grad an den küsten und 20 grad im
westen
das nehmen wir jetzt mal einfach so mit
und bedanken uns mit diesen guten
aussichten für ihr interesse
claus kleber hat das heute-journal
nachher ab morgen ist hier petra gerster
für sie da
aber erst kommt jetzt theo koll ich
wünsche ihnen einen sehr angenehmen
sonntagabend und denselben wünschen